Speaker 1: So Donald Trump has essentially ruled
out that Mike Pence would be his vice presidential
running mate if he were to run for president again
in 2024, and this is not particularly surprising
given the last 14 months of the things that Donald
Trump has said about Mike Pence. But it does
make 2024 significantly more interesting. A
president running again after losing reelection
with a different running mate is interesting, and
this we have learned, thanks to an interview that
Donald Trump gave to the Washington Examiner
earlier this week. Washington Examiner writing
Trump now in this. I know Washington Examiner is
not what we typically use as a source, but this
is the primary source here. This was an interview
that they did. Trump says Pence partnership over
as ex-president eyes 2024 comeback bid Former
President Donald Trump is effectively ruling out
ruling out tapping former VP Mike Pence as his
running mate should he mount a third White House
bid in 2024 and win the Republican nomination
quote. I don't think the people would accept it,
Trump told the Washington Examiner Tuesday
evening during a telephone interview that he
gave from Mar a Lago. The former president cited
friction stemming from the aftermath of the 2020
election. It's funny to call it friction. You try
to get the guy to do something illegal. Describing
that as friction is interesting, suggesting their
differences are too stark to overcome. I would
agree with that. Trump claimed the contest
was stolen and wanted Pence to overturn the
results during the congressional certification
of Biden's victory. You can't. Pence, who in his
capacity as Senate president, was presiding
over the certification proceedings, refused,
explaining the Constitution granted him no
authority. It's interesting to call it a refusal.
It's really an inability. He can't do it. He can't
do it now, as the article says, and as Trump said.
Trump continues to insist otherwise. He pointed
to bipartisan talks on Capitol Hill to reform
the Electoral Count Act, the law governing the
congressional certification. We've talked about
that already. Trump said, Mike and I had a great
relationship, except for the very important factor
that took place at the end. We had a very
good relationship. I haven't spoken to him
in a long time. Now there's a couple different
things that that can be talked about here. First,
we're upping the uniqueness, uniqueness factor
in some sense, because if Trump runs, he would
also run. He will have run after losing and pick
a different VP. It'll be interesting from like a
historical perspective. I also can't avoid saying
that the danger factor would likely be greater
because Trump could pick someone that might
be more assertive and more dangerous and more
useful to him. Trump is reportedly mad at Florida
Gov. Ron DeSantis right now. But imagine if Trump
partnered up with DeSantis, who is much more
delusional than Pence in a particular way.
And I would argue much more assertive and
able to get things done. Pence has conceded
that he didn't have the ability to overturn the
election, and that was a nice enough to put him on
Trump's naughty list. Now, for Mike Pence's part,
he was on Maria Bartiromo as FOX Business show
not that long ago on March 8th, and she asked him
about What are you thinking for 24? Do you want to
see Trump run? And here's how Pence answered it.
Speaker 6: Mr. Vice President, before you go
a word on twenty twenty four. Do
you want President Trump to run?
Are you looking to get back into your leadership?
Speaker 2: You know, all of my focus right now is
on twenty twenty two. I think we have a historic
opportunity to reclaim majorities in the House and
the Senate to elect great Republican governors
around America. And in twenty twenty three, I'm
I'm confident the Republican Party
will nominate a candidate who will be
the next president of the United States
of America and at the right time,
my family and I will reflect and consider
how we might participate in that process.
Speaker 1: But yeah, so not really.
Answering the question, I think of
note are how the betting markets are looking
at this so far. If you look that predicted
right now, thirty nine cents of every dollar are
being bet on Trump being the Republican nominee
very close at this point, twenty seven cents
of every dollar are behind. Ron DeSantis, being
the Republican nominee and in a pretty distant
fourth place, are six cents on the dollar behind
Mike Pence being the eventual Republican nominee.
I think there is almost no chance in hell that
Mike Pence ends up as the Republican nominee.
But needless to say, it'll be an interesting 2024